bonjour françois bayrou bonjour
l'assemblée nationale se penche
aujourd'hui sur la question de
l'euthanasie est ce que la france doit
l'autoriser l'aide à la fin de vie
lorsque les jours sont comptés lorsqu'on
sait que c'est fini c'est déjà dans la
loi la question qui se pose est que
posent les auteurs eux mêmes de la loi
actuelle c est ce que la loi est
appliquée mais aidé quelqu'un qu'on aime
une femme nomme refuser l'acharnement
thérapeutique
en effet c'est la philosophie de la loi
et c'est ce qui doit être au fond la
liberté et le dialogue entre médecins et
malades
alors est-ce qu'il faut changer la loi
appliquons là d'abord ce que disent les
auteurs de la loi je vous rappelle que
cette loi a été votée à l'unanimité de
l'assemblée nationale toute philosophie
toutes tendances confondues et ce que
disent les auteurs de la loi ceux qui
l'ont porté ses elle n'est pas appliquée
comme elle devrait l'être bas appliquons
là mais cette question est évidemment
une question qui se pose et c'est une
question de philosophie personnelle dans
laquelle chacun mesure combien elle est
délicate et probablement essentiel mais
votre père position personnelle sur ce
point c'est que la vie est trop
précieuse outreau sacré pour qu'on
puisse choisir de soi même de l'arrêté
vous poser une autre question est là qui
n'est pas la question de l'euthanasie
qu'est la question du suicide assisté et
j'ai dit je crois à ce micro même que
pour moi c'était une question parce que
il se trouve que quand on voit des êtres
qui vous sont chers passé
par des horreurs pour être obligé de
quitter la vie on se dit que ma foi il y
aurait probablement des démarches plus
humaine alors c'est ma position
personnelle elle n'est absolument pas
une consigne à qui que ce soit vous
dites que c'est une question ça veut
dire qu'elle doit être abordée à
l'assemblée nationale parce que
concrètement ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
il ne va pas l'être dans ce cadre c'est
pas la même c'est pas la même
philosophie mais est ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin que la sédation profonde c'est
à dire permettre un malade qui ne peut
pas guérir bas 2-2 de s'endormir en fait
c'est ce qui existe aujourd'hui mais
s'il faut passer second réactive c'est
ce qui se fait voler plus loin c'est ce
qui se fait tous les jours dans un très
grand nombre d'hôpitaux et de cliniques
et dans le dialogue silencieux les yeux
dans les yeux qu'il y as entre un
médecin sont malades et la famille du
malade le plus souvent ça se fait tous
les jours
est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit dans les
codes avec des normes et des règles vous
sentez bien qu'il ya là quelque chose
qui ouvre des questions qui sont des
questions si profonde qu'on ne peut les
aborder qu'avec beaucoup de prudence moi
j'ai beaucoup admiré le travail qu'on
fait leonetti etc laissent les deux
auteurs de la loi précédente
parce que si vous mesurez l'éventail des
philosophies des convictions religieuses
des
croyance ou d athéisme ou des
agnosticisme et à quel point ce travail
est délicat
ces deux hommes d'orientation
philosophique différentes
ils ont réussi à écrire un texte qui a
convaincu la totalité des nuances de
l'assemblée nationale et j'ai beaucoup
admiré ce travail parce que c'était un
travail de conscience et de délicatesse
françois bayrou emmanuel macron réunit
tout à l'heure la haute fonction
publique il pourrait il devrait annoncer
la suppression de l'enad pour être là
mais depuis des années et des années ça
y est vous avez eu la tête de l'ena il
faut encore ça ne fait pas comme ça que
ça ce que ça se joue en effet j'ai ça a
été un de mes chevaux de bataille depuis
longtemps et c'est un sujet de
préoccupation pour le président de la
république tous les jours depuis la
campagne électorale de 2010 est pourquoi
à mon avis ya deux raisons profondes la
première de ces raisons c'est que parmi
les problèmes vitaux de la france il y
en a un que vous constatez tous les
jours c'est la rupture absolue entre la
base de la société
ceux qui travaillent ceux qui sont à la
retraite ceux qui sont au chômage les
femmes et les hommes qui occupent toutes
les fonctions de la société les jeunes
les étudiants et le prétendu sommet
rupture entre la base et ceux qui sont
en haut mais ena ou pas il y aura
toujours un sommaire une base un jeu
peut-être on peut réformer les hauts
fonctionnaires il faudra peut-être
réfléchir à cette question donc je dis
rupture et deuxième problème qui va avec
c'est un système inefficace de blocage
perpétuelle qui fait qu' on ne peut
jamais rien changé
monsieur le président c'est impossible
monsieur le ministre c'est impossible
l'administration ne supporte que le
président de la république oui
l'immobilisme est plus fort que toutes
les énergies déployées mais est-ce que
ça c'est en supprimant les nac tout ça
va changer
mais c'est en réfléchissant à un mode de
sélection
et de formation qui soit différent il ya
un corps dans la société française qui à
mon avis a réussit admirablement à
traiter cette question en tout cas de
manière remarquable caisse et l'armée
l'armée a choisi un système de formation
et de sélection de ceux qui occuperont
des responsabilités qui intervient en
fait beaucoup plus tard dans la vie
l'ena si c'est à 20 ans 21 22 ans
et si après on est de toute façon
sélectionnés vous voyez bien qu'il ya
quelque chose qui ne tient pas compte
des qualités humaines et de l'aptitude à
l'action au commandement et donc l'armée
en créant l'école de guerre à 35 ans qui
est le le passage le quart faut pour les
grandes responsabilités en mettant
beaucoup de soin à sélectionner ceux
qu'ils appellent les potentiels les
potentiels et au potentiel tout ce dont
on devine dont on se dit qu'ils pourront
avoir les qualités nécessaires pour
conduire les hommes et conduire les
batailles ils ont fait un travail
absolument remarquable et qui se fait
tout au long de la vie françois bayrou
emmanuel macron a déjà annoncé le
changement de recrutement à l'ena
c'était il ya quelques semaines sur
lorsqu'il a annoncé ses mesures pour
l'égalité des chances
ces annonces elles ont déjà eu lieu
qu'est ce qu'il va y avoir de nouveau
cet après midi en fait on va changer le
nom
eh bien vous voyez ce ce qui est le plus
simple c'est que vous écoutiez jeu je ne
les les annonces du président de la
république à partir du président de
l'aplm et si on suit moi j'essaie de me
choquerait une nouvelle école qui aura
sans doute un nouveau nom ça change quoi
dans la sélection de ce qui vous était
pas bhl et les élites mais des futurs
cadres de l'administration
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut en
partant de la base
en partant des milieux non privilégiés
de la culture ou de la société est-ce
qu'on peut accéder aux responsabilités
majeures de la société française pendant
disons la première partie du 20ème
siècle c'était possible vous vous
incluez dans cette catégorie
dans ce guide vous êtes d'une famille
plutôt modeste oui vous êtes là vous
êtes heureusement donc ça veut dire
parfois ça marche l'ascenseur ou
l'escalier l'ascenseur je ne suis pas
certain qu'ils puissent marcher
aujourd'hui comme il a marché
quand je suis entré dans cette dans ce
chemin là qui est un chemin d'une
aventure personnelle le je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui les choses sont beaucoup
plus bloquer beaucoup plus à durer il ya
une question qui se pose je parlais de
l'efficacité l'état devrait être là pour
soutenir les initiatives de la société
française les initiatives des personnes
des des associations des entreprises
pour aider et la plupart du temps il
n'est pas là pour aider idée là pour
bloquer parce que l'état a connu une
dérive l'état est devenu administration
et l'administration est devenu
bureaucratie et ce système là que cette
mécanique là qui s'impose même si les
gens sont généreux brillant volontaire
s'ils ont cette cette âme
cette vitalité de changer les choses
perpétuellement ça les blocs je vais
prendre un exemple eux
vous allez le prendre si vous voulez
bien dans une minute dans une jeune
couple à 18h42 le fil info diane faire
chic
emmanuel macron l'avait promis il ya
deux ans le chef de l'état a annoncé
aujourd'hui la suppression de l'ena
l'ena qui sera remplacée par une
nouvelle haute école de la fonction
publique
les bénéfices du vaccin astrazeneca
supérieurs aux risques c'est l'avis des
autorités sanitaires européennes elle
conclut un lien possible entre le sérum
anglo suédois et des cas graves de
thrombose le vaccin sera zeneca toujours
suspendue dans certains pays limité aux
plus de 60 ans dans d'autres en france
il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas
continuer de l'utiliser sur les
personnes âgées de 55 ans et plus et
steam sur france info alain fischer le
président du conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale le compagnon
d'aurélie vacquiers en garde à vue après
la découverte d'un corps sous une dalle
de béton à son domicile dans l'hérault
très vraisemblablement le corps de la
jeune femme disparue fin janvier
l'enquêté requalifier en enquête pour
meurtre l'exploit du pg qui s'est imposé
à munich 3 à 2 face au bayern dont un
doublé de kylie ann m bape et lors de ce
match aller des quarts de finale de
ligue des champions les parisiens qui
devront un confirmé mardi lors du match
retour au parc des princes
franceinfo le 8 30 france info samia ben
radhia marc fauvelle toujours avec le
président du modem et au commissaire au
plan françois bayrou vouliez donner un
exemple de ce qui selon vous ne
fonctionne pas aujourd'hui en france
c'est à dire du blocage perpétuelle du
constat par tout un appareil qui choisit
toujours l'immobilisme qu'on peut pas
bouger
on a un problème électoral l'épidémie
entre en collision avec des élections
prévues c'était déjà le cas aux
municipales et c'est à nouveau le cas on
en parlera peut-être les régionales
d'après temps une minute
il ya une chose très simple à faire qui
est le vote par correspondance ce que
tous les pays autour de nous on fait ce
que je réclame comme vous savez je vois
votre sourire depuis depuis longtemps
comme que presque comme une obsession
les allemands pu tenir leur élection
parce qu'ils ont le vote par
correspondance
de très nombreux pays européens et aux
états unis 100 millions d'américains ont
voté par correspondance pour élire le
président et administration si on ne le
fait pas en france donc on le demande
des responsables disent mais pourquoi on
fait pas ça et la réponse qui vient de
ce mélange administratives aux
politiques
c'est monsieur ça n'est pas possible
monsieur le président ce n'est pas
possible monsieur le ministre ce n'est
pas possible
alors vous vous arracher les cheveux le
président le président aussi bien des
risques de fraude
le prg m mais c'est une vaste blague
donald moment je sais bien que je le
pense comme d'abord il m'a entendu le
dire à votre micro est assez souvent à
vos micros assez souvent
comment peut-on dire qu'il n'est pas
possible
vous savez les allemands le vote par
correspondance la cour suprême allemande
a décidé il ya plus de vingt ans qu'elle
ne prendrait plus jamais aucune plainte
pour fraude sur le vote par
correspondance parce que vérifications
avaient été faites par des procédures
innombrables
il n'y avait pas de faute 100 millions
d'américains on n'a pas trouvé une
fraude
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que raconte ce
qui qui choisissent perpétuellement de
ne rien changer
même ce qui correspond au bon sens le
plus élémentaire
c'est le bon séance éléments créés par
le gouvernement et peuple et pas par le
président de la république pour le vote
par correspondance et bien moi je crois
que je le suis mais on va voir des
jeunes je suis persuadé que pour les
régionales
ça dépend de la date à laquelle les
régions dans cette ronde a lieu au mois
de juin on va peut-être venir à ce alors
s'il vous plaît nous n'aurons pas si au
moins curieux non non ce n'est pas la
bonne question à question est ce qu ils
focalisaient la nouvelle édition fait la
dette à ce pays qui voulait inscrire
fait qu'elle ait lieu au mois de juin
oui on est dans une période d'épidémie
on est dans un moment où tout le monde
le voit bien toutes les collectivités
toutes les communes toutes les villes
suppriment leur fait leur comice
agricole leurs concerts tout est bloqué
c'est pas forcément la même ambiance
dans un bureau de vote
et on dit que on va cependant tenir sans
le moindre changement
une élection dans lequel la campagne
électorale ne va pas pouvoir avoir lieu
et où les mères disent mais c'est pas
possible on ne peut pas le faire je vais
vous donner une preuve simple mais les
maires nous avons consulté
le groupe du modem du mouvement
démocrate nous avons consulté tous les
maires des circonscriptions des 60 ou 58
députés de notre groupe
les maires à plus de 80 % disent on ne
peut pas le faire et je j'apporte une
preuve toute simple dans l'audit le
conseil scientifique scientifique qui
s'occupe de la santé a dit il faut que
tous les assesseurs soient vaccinés il
faudrait les formations que tous les
donc c'est une obligation
il faut que tous les assesseurs soient
vaccinés est ce que vous connaissez les
axes et les assesseurs cinq semaines à
l'avance la vérité c'est que les
assesseurs dans les bureaux de vote tout
mer qu'est la moindre expérience et
qu'ils les trouvent dans les trois
derniers jours et si on les connaissait
à l'avancé alors ça veut dire qu'ils
vont avoir la priorité sur les
enseignants sur les personnels d'un
certain nombre de services publics
vitaux
tout ceci est irréaliste donc on
repousse les élections à canal et à moi
et après le gouvernement a sa
responsabilité l'assemblée nationale si
mon avis à moi c'est que il n'est pas
raisonnable de tenir les élections dans
un moment où l'attention des citoyens et
portait sur des questions aussi graves
que la santé la maladie les piles
évidemment ces régionales ces
départements après l'été mais c'est ce
que dit le conseil scientifique entre
les lignes il dit après l'été en effet
il y aurait un fait nouveau c'est que
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
français seront vaccinés donc le risque
géographes des crues jean castex doit
donner sa réponse après consultation des
forces politiques vous est-ce que vous
en avez parlé à jean castex est ce que
vous avez parler au président de la
république oui et vous ont répondu qu
est-ce qui vous ont répondu d'abord je
ne raconte jamais courir sans cesse avec
eux mais enfin en tout cas il me
consulter pour savoir comme responsable
et ça les fait hésiter
c'est ça la question je pense que oui
c'est une question qui est dans leur
esprit oui mais aussi de consulter les
maires et les maires de chacune des
communes demandons-leur
et on va voir que la réponse vous savez
on a 70 mille bureaux de vote
combien de personnes pour participer à
ces bureaux de vote
allez si vous avez dit candidature faut
à peu près une dizaine de personnes ça
fait sept cent mille personnes qui tout
réussit est-ce que c'est réaliste
on a vécu au premier tour des élections
municipales
un drame dans laquelle nous connaissons
vous connaissez je connais des femmes et
des hommes qui ont contracté la maladie
qui sont morts et certains étaient mes
amis
est ce que est ce qu'on continue en
fermant les yeux
moi je pense que la raison ça serait de
dire on veut te ra après l'été et
deuxièmement on va tout de suite se
mettre à créer les conditions du vote
par correspondance pour tous les
français qui le souhaiteront voilà
message envoyé à gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur il est 8h 50 on
se retrouve dans un instant françois
bayrou le fil info tout d'abord avec
diane faire pschitt
[Musique]
2 38 millions de foyers fiscaux sont
concernées mis en ligne ce jeudi de la
déclaration des revenus 2020 dans le
contexte sanitaire actuelle certain fred
télétravail seront exonérés les tailles
devenue une administration et
l'administration est devenue une
bureaucratie les mots vous venez de
l'entendre à l'instant sur france info
de françois bayrou président du modem et
au haut commissaire au plan alors qu
emmanuel macron annoncera cet après-midi
la suppression de l'ena une promesse du
président fait au moment de la crise des
gilet jaune les caillots sanguins
doivent être répertoriés comme un effet
secondaire très rare du vaccin
astrazeneca contre le coc vide
conclusions de l'agencé européenne du
médicament après des cas de thrombose
mortels 19 sur 25 millions de vaccinés
en europe mais les bénéfices l'emportent
sur le risque en france lastras zeneca
est réservé aux personnes de plus de 55
ans
l'assemblée nationale examine ce jeudi
une proposition de loi pour créer un
droit à l'euthanasie pour les personnes
souffrant d'une pathologie incurable
un texte qui n'a quasiment aucune chance
d'être adoptée plus de trois mille
amendements déposés alors que
l'assemblée nationale n'a qu'une seule
journée pour se pencher sur ce texte
france info
le 8 30 france info sabia brasilia marc
fauvelle françois bayrou vous êtes
chargé par le gouvernement et par
emmanuel macron de réfléchir à la france
de 2050 2060 aux états unis joe biden
vient de se lancer dans des hausses
assez massives d'impôts pour les
entreprises le taux d'imposition des
entreprises qui est aujourd'hui de 21 %
va passer à 28 %
si on regarde dans le détail ça veut
dire que les impôts que paieront les
entreprises américaines seront plus
élevés que les entreprises françaises du
même ordre par exemple 25% l'an prochain
en france
ce même 28 % aux etats-unis est-ce que
pour rembourser la dette il va falloir
que les entreprises payent alors je ne
crois pas qu'il faille cibler les
entreprises
alain rousset lui ni très mauvaise idée
mais ce que vous avez oublié de dire
c'est que la décision principale du
président des états unis de joe biden
c'est de mettre sur la table
deux mille milliards de dollars
supplémentaires en plus des plans de
relance et monétaires ce qui au total
fera 5500 milliards voulait dire qu'on
est trop de donnera en france et donc
comme vous savez moi je plaide pour un
plan marshall de reconquête de la
production industrielle agricole de
service pour regagner tout ce que nous
avons perdu en parts de marché la france
est aujourd'hui décroché dans son
commerce extérieur
parce que nous n'arrivons pas à fournir
la demande qui est celle des
consommateurs mais cet argent vous avez
combattu pendant des années à l'idée
qu'on puisse laisser filer la droite on
le trouve ou si c'est en augmentant les
impôts nous sommes avec la dette vous
serez déçu si vous aviez suivi du bon
travail ces dernières semaines
nous sommes dans un moment où par une
chance inouïe historique
on peut emprunter quasiment à zéro pour
cent cinquante agents qu'il faudra
rembourser à la veille donc ma
proposition c'est que cet argent investi
pour redresser l'économie française on
laisse dix ans de délai pour que l'effet
se sentent et on le rembourse après sur
30 ans
comment on fait on le rembourse sur 30
ans avec les rentrées y compris les
rentrées fiscales
l'augmentation des impôts encore une
fois encore une fois non puisque je ne
paie pas pour ça je reviens sur le jeu
et qu'ils soient très faible aujourd'hui
ou même parfois légèrement négative
quand on emprunte de l'argent
ok on emprunte de l'argent pas cher mais
l'argent à la fin il faudra le
rembourser
et si vous le rembourser sur 30 ans si
pendant ce temps vous avez gagné des
parts de marché de la croissance si la
production s'est relancée alors vous
créer de nouvelles sources de revenu
pour les impôts et de nouvelles sources
de cotisations sociales pour faire
marcher le système ses 7,7 vie cette
vitalité reconquise qui nous permettra
de rembourser sans difficulté les impôts
j'ai fait un calcul j'ai proposé dans
une note du plan un calcul qui fait que
onze on s'aperçoit que cet effort là
dans dix ans sera parfaitement
supportable dès l'instant qu'on aura
retrouvé le rythme de création et de
production qui est le nôtre tir de notre
climat chaud quentin qui fait beaucoup
réagir nous vient d'ankara en turquie
le président du conseil européen charles
michel et la présidente de la commission
ursula von der leyen ont été reçus par
le président turc avant-hier problème
lorsqu'il a fallu s'installer pour
l'entretien il n'y avait que deux sièges
pour les hommes
ursula von der leyen elle a dû
s'installer sur un canapé à côté à
l'écart c'est une gaffe protocolaire du
machisme du sexisme ou alors de la
provocation alors si c'est voulu c'est
inacceptable et les deux responsables
européens auraient dû s'accorder pour
que ce soit selon nos traditions
madame van der leyen qui qui se tenait
en premier donc chercher leur est dû à
son lancement dont je donne pas de leçon
de ce genre à des responsables
politiques par ailleurs j'apprécie et
donc ça c'est le premier point mais il
est possible que ça ne soit pas voulu
comme vous avez vu il ya des
contributions des articles de
journalistes briand qui explique que non
c'était vraiment un accident
protocolaire parce qu'on n'avait pas
fait la préparation nécessaire sauf
qu'il est déjà arrivé par le passé que
le président turc reçoivent le président
de la commission le président du conseil
quand il s'agissait quand il s'agissait
des hommes il y avait trois sièges et
bien donc c'est inacceptable si c'est un
geste voulu et voulue pour créer une
différence est une humiliation
supplémentaire parce que le responsable
politique enfin c'est une femme c'est
inacceptable dans ces cas là on fait
quoi
bah j'en sais rien on dit que c'est
inacceptable on proteste et ont fait
savoir que plus jamais y aura
d'entretenir de cet ordre si c'est si
ces dispositions ne sont pas prises il
ya un homme qu'on voit beaucoup en ce
moment dans les médias françois bayrou
c'est edouard philippe l'ancien premier
ministre qui dit d'interview en
interview qu'il est à la fois loyal et
libre
j'ai compris ce que ça veut dire loyal
et l'iman très bien le mot loyal je
comprends très bien le mot libre
j'essaie moi même d'être tout le monde
dirigeants en harmonie avec ces deux
mots là mais l'idée dans la même phrase
est ce que ça veut dire quelque chose
moi j'en sais rien les journalistes
c'est vous vous êtes brillant si vous
êtes intelligent vous êtes attentif et
vous êtes avisés et donc c'est pas moi
qui vais vous donner des leçons
d'interprétation des messages
subliminaux qui vous est ce loyal ou
plus libre avec emmanuel macron les deux
et xavier par exemple vous n'avez pas de
doute sur ce que vous ferez dans un an à
l'élection présidentielle exactement je
suis pleinement engagée dans le soutien
à ce que
le président de la république fait par
délégation des français parce que
l'élection de 2017 ce qui a échappé à
beaucoup de gens c'était pour moi une
élection tournant c'était une élection
tournant parce que les français donnés
au président de la république
la mission de changer les rapports entre
le pouvoir et le peuple entre le haut et
la base de la société
et ceci n'a pas pu se faire pendant des
années c'est extrêmement courageux de la
part du président de la république de
s'y attaquer aujourd'hui même comme
comme vous l'avait annoncé et j'espère
at il des messieurs emmanuel macron non
sur yon moi je vais vous dire la ce la
question que je me suis posée tout au
long de ma vie politique à la fois
engagée dans l'élection présidentielle
et observant le pouvoir la question que
je me suis posée c'est est ce que ceux
qui ont les responsabilités sont à la
hauteur de l'histoire et ma certitude ce
que je ressens du plus profond c'est que
cet homme là est à la hauteur de
l'histoire et c'est une histoire
tellement difficile dans les temps que
nous vivons ce sont des temps de de
bouleversement profond on en a énuméré
un certain nombre entre nous deux il
faut une énergie formidable et une
conscience formidable pour oser faire
bouger ce qui tellement bloquée depuis
tant et tant de décennies et donc non
moi je n'ai
je n'ai eu aucun doute sur ces 40
dernières dernière question réponse par
oui ou non si vous voulez bien si on
vous propose demain matin de vous faire
vacciner avec astrazeneca vous y aller
ou pas oui merci bonne journée à vous
françois bayrou